it's a pleasure to speak with you today
hi liz so i i don't have a lot of time
with you so i want to just dive in
so as a survivor of the original holiday
special
what what does it mean to you to be
involved with this particular version
you are so right i was horrified when
they came to me and said we are making
a uh an animation called the holiday
special and i said are you crazy
people remember they'll hate you for
doing it again
and of course when you see the script
the program is totally different
but i talk about the the holiday special
in my new
out in paperback book i am c-3po the
inside story
and one of my favorite chapters in there
is about the original
holiday special how it felt on the set
and how am i
i'm so happy to escape from it but this
one
is totally different and they very
quickly reassured me
first of all we're all lego and who
doesn't like lego who doesn't like all
those
critters being the same size and walking
in that strange
not even robotic but it's kind of lumpy
way
that it's so cute and you know all their
hair turns just everybody's lumpy
and i know that's one of chewbacca's
cousins or something
from the original oh god you see it's in
my head um
and this one yeah lego and in lego you
can poke fun at
the big the big bear moth
star wars and all that it means to
millions and millions and millions of
people around the planet
you know we all know star wars is just a
global
massive thing that is revered and loved
but when is something so big and revered
and loved you can tease it you can poke
fun of it because
at heart you'll love it and so lego is
teasing here
they're taking you on adventures that
you wouldn't normally be able to go
on meet people together that would
normally mix
and so on and all heading to this great
event that walkers
live for life day and that is so
echoes a lot of stuff that we as humans
do on our planet you know we've all got
our religious
festivals that have a high point maybe
this year
it's going to be slightly lower
and we've got to get through that and
move on to next year
this year is to have this program out
that you can enjoy
at home on a screen near you by yourself
is full of love and affection and warmth
if you bite yourself
and if you're with a family it's going
to echo what
what's around you until of course the
family row breaks up but
it breaks out at christmas normally
would people put together for too long
you know in terms of doing this
character do you feel possessive of him
at a certain level
like you unlike a lot of star wars
characters you're consistently
relatively consistently usually doing
the voice
that is a very very um perceptive
question
um disney and lucasfilm would be
horrified to think i had
any sense of possession about it and
they've always been very clear
it's theirs he belongs to us
be grateful but yes i've
i have to be very careful um
about how i feel possessive about him
because he's not
he isn't me he doesn't belong to me but
because
i've been doing him so long i'm the kind
of guardian of who he is on this planet
and i've said that to jj
i am his spokesperson on this planet and
um if people are sensible they kind of
listen to me that i have the history
here that 3po wouldn't actually behave
like that because it was out of
character out of
dialogue it's vocabulary whatever and
most people um kind of say oh thanks
thanks for the advice yeah we'll change
it you know
nothing big it's just their little
moments that make 3po
the consistent character from your child
and from
your parents uh lifetime younger days
that he has to stay the same absolutely
one thing i definitely want to ask you
about when people
talk to you about the relationship
between c-3po and r2d2
how do you describe it is it is it are
they just good friends is it a long
lasting marriage
it it is like there's that wonderful
film the odd couple
you'll remember where these two guys
different personalities
but they they have little uh little
connections between
each other and one of the things of
course between those two droids
is they go on horrible adventures that
bring out the best and the worst of them
and
i one of the things i liked in georgia's
script originally
was the way he had written um you know
there's this humanoid figure and this
box
an utter utterly believable um
relationship dialogue and so on that you
really felt you were talking to
listening to humans the shocking thing
for me the genuinely shocking thing
for me was on the first day of filming
six months after i had begun my
involvement with the costume
there we were in the desert and in all
that time
nobody had said to me you realize r2d2
does not make any sound
that will be put in later so on day one
i'm going
i i don't understand how to do this i'm
acting
with with this thing that doesn't relate
to me and i'm having to have a
conversation
and i got through it and of course in
the end it was ben bert
who put on those wonderful beeps and
burbles and whistles and
those funny noises that slotted around
my dialogue monologue so when i saw the
original
i was absolutely thrilled at
ben burt having created um the other
half
of the act and making it such a lovable
thing that we
we see the humanity in there for all
it's it's good and
naughty side and it's uh it's it's
frustration
because they're putting very frustrating
situations
as are most of us for heaven's sake you
know time's a bit frustrating at the
moment and
today's been a little weird so but um
fortunately arto isn't here today to
annoy me
um so it's that's good wonderful that's
my time with you thank you so much
and have a great rest of your day thank
you and
happy life day and may the force
be with you and with you